pulei tanto pelo vibra o gasto pessoal
aqui quem fala é dar que diz muito bem
vindos
a mãe dele a mostrar que não era muito
comum é bom só comprei que um
microscópio e tecnologia que na minha
não tem muita tecnologia espaço pessoal
basicamente eu vou conseguir observar
tudo aquilo que eu quiser ampliado - ea
maneira que não costumava ver muitas
coisas ao microscópio animais e eu
escreveria o furto não só estávamos tipo
eu gosto é composto por bactérias têm
milhares de aranhas dentro do grupo não
tem muito porque ele nos encanta
provavelmente fotos nunca viram né nem o
sistema nem só de insetos mri orgulho
desse tipo texturas de materiais de
espera
então meu décimo título mas como vocês
podem ver pelo título hoje nós vamos ver
então o meu corpo vamos ver como é que a
minha pele do meu cabelo meu organismo
substâncias meu eu tenho muitas picadas
de mosquito vamos mostrar também como é
que elas estão por dentro eu ainda não
vi mas é futebol gente mas já sabem
pessoal nós vamos bater aqui com uma
meta vamos tentar então espero que o meu
pai que existe em nós quando estarão os
milagres no vôo e fora o jovem e vou
cansar todos e princesas que
encontrarmos tipo lagarto não está
intensa plano pode pista quanto é bicho
maria bicho café maria por ligas velho
gol valeu chuva o demônio
vou tentar encontrar todo o sucesso
possível fechar um dos pilares é como
vocês podem ver não só tem a imagem do
microscópio estava identificado porque
ainda não tenho um álbum né mas vamos lá
com isso dois vai o ovo não só pessoal
smp um visú mil meu
olha só o zoom texto eu tenho muita
sujeira mercado olha nem orgulha o ol
não acredito eu vejo muito bem os pneus
olinda barba meu juiz de fora
o último pelo mulheres não só continuar
[Música]
ano gento meu amigo é casa cheia de
gordura espanha cujo foco agora é
começar a rua tal formação sobre postura
dos pêlos meu mato grosso chico sujidade
aqui mas não só não tem muita gordura e
ainda tem no meu cabelo agora 32 vai
[Música]
brotar eu vejo mudanças coisa que tem
muito mais escuro aqui começa a ficar
mais claro não saiu do papel meu ver
tudo na língua alemã para tentar ver o
meu dengo hora foi sujeito está em meu
tá muito sujo
ok só agora vamos à margem bastante e
tenho aqui picadas de mosquitos na minha
perna e vamos ver como é que elas estão
microscópio
o game tinha infecção da picada do
mosquito falar do nosso corpo
olha aí tá tudo infectava euros tem pela
evento não dá prazer em atentei acho que
já tivera e apoio pelo embora mesmo está
muito nojento ver mais um mas eu tenho
orgulho gay
vejam só como ela não é muito é muito
nojento tem 15 pelo que fiz no meu braço
e eu não sei quanto em vendas de é o
rival não estava comigo no shopping para
mandar prender muito bem mas nota-se que
já tem uma diferença do bela olha só
essa é aquela cicatriz meu bairro
estranho tem coisas postas querem que eu
vejo com microscopy pode ser qualquer
coisa que eu faça um vídeo aí mas
deixem-me wipe prf de metal nem como é
tão esquecida vamos ver um lirismo ao
banco e nem deve ao fato de sua empresa
[Música]
não pode ter uma idéia eu vou chamar
aqui alguém que já está em casa e vamos
ver o corpo de deus que veste a pele de
30 minha e ela é diferente do meu
estava em casa é ruim não
mas agora pelo forro estranha ainda mais
estranho na minha frente um velho
[Música]
agora meu pequeno e só agora vamos fazer
uma competição de lins vamos ver quem
tem tênis mais limpo embora lá eu vou
começar o meu mans da lei
o empenho não está 100 mas não se fala
mais complicada que com espírito já
sabem se vocês quiserem mais vídeos
deste ano assim como microscópios e
outras coisas loucas mas não faz
milagres neste vídeo e nós vamos
capturar em tétum de fora e vamos ver em
séries como microscópios ottawa enquanto
o nosso leque comentário que rivais mais
próximos vídeos como você tá aqui ó
mundo e aqui em baixo podem ser mesmo
aqui no canal d'arc i fica mais avanços
de márcio
[Música]